Before we go on,
let me introduce myself.
My name's Andy, and three years ago,
I couldn't code at all.
Now I can, and
I want to tell you how that happened.
I graduated from college in
2009 with a degree in physics.
And I had no coding skill at all.
And at the time, I was actually
pretty intimidated by programming.
Even though I didn't start
learning to code until 2012,
these three years from 2009 to 2012,
are relevant to how I learned to code.
Because it was during this time that
I was doing a lot of teaching and
a lot of learning about
how people learn.
And I learned something that would wind
up being incredibly important to me.
When I would eventually learn to code.
I learned that anyone
can learn anything.
Well, just about anyone can
learn just about anything.
But for the most part, this is true,
because even though everyone has
different backgrounds and experiences
when you get down to the level of
brains they're all very similar.
And our brain is also this
incredibly flexible thing.
By giving it the right input you
can actually change your brain and
make it do whatever you want.
But, that's enough about the brain.
After three years of teaching and
learning, sometime in early February of
2012, I heard about this new
education company called Udacity.
That was actually what the logo
looked like at the time.
I didn't know much about it, but online
education sounded really interesting, so
I emailed someone who worked there.
Three days later,
I was on a plane to San Francisco.
It was very exciting.
But things at Udacity were
pretty chaotic back then, and
nobody had even told me
what my job would be,
though I assumed it had something to
do with education and maybe technology.
Either way,
February 15th was my first day of work,
and I would figure it out then.
That morning, I got dropped off at
our office, which, at the time,
was just Sebastian, who's our CEO.
It was his house.
So, I walk to the door, I still didn't
know what my role would be, but
that was going to change
in about 30 seconds.
I rang the bell and Sebastian answered.
Our conversation went
something like this.
He told me that I would be the assistant
instructor for the course he was making.
This was news to me, but
I was trying to play it cool.
So I asked him to remind me of
the title and then he told me.
The course was called CS373 How
to Program a Robotic Car.
And I was terrified.
I didn't know anything about
programming or robotics.
And I might have quit right then,
if I hadn't remembered that lesson.
And because I really believe
that anyone can learn anything,
I started learning and
I haven't stopped.
And now, here I am today.
Very, very excited to be assembling
the resource I wish I had had
three years ago.
Now, you may be thinking, why should
I entrust my programming education
to someone who only has
three years of experience?
And the answer is,
you shouldn't and you aren't.
Let me explain how this
non-degree is going to work.